Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to my bathroom.
I don't know why I'm welcoming you to that,
but I'm filming in here because it looks pretty
and the lighting is... very nice
with the window, and the mirror... and...
creating a... light gradient... a cr- anyway...
So ever since the last Joy of Creation video
there's been a lot of concern about my health.
Like, oddly enough I've been getting emails
and tweets about m-my need to get sleep,
and I haven't been told to go to bed since my mom
told me to go to bed when I was...
living in her basement... at the prime age of 22. [laughs]
So I appreciate the concern, but I also
wanted to reassure you guys that
I am doing just fine and I've been
managing the schedule for a long time
and, uh, veterans of the channel will confirm this.
Like, those of you out there who've been watching for
two, three, or four years will note that
I've ALLLLWAYS been late.
I live my life in a state of
perpetual panic and, uh, I-
I actually established this schedule last year, and I said,
[with exaggerated enthusiasm] "I'm gonna do this! It's gonna be eight and twelve every day!"
And then like immediately, 2 days later, I totally
missed the schedule and then I've been struggling to maintain it ever since...
And that's fine... I do the best I can!
And when Matt came along that helped me out incredibly.
You'll notice that like, as soon as Matt started
helping me edit... like, things got way more consistent,
because I was able to get his help on editing videos.
Uhh, an- and in the past few weeks he hasn't been able
to help me because he's been taking care of stuff on his own
And that's totally fine, but that
just leaves me back into my cycle of life.
So, I wanted to show you guys
exactly what it was to be a Markiplier
in a daily life of my life.
So, here's...
[fake yawn] AARRGH!
[constant screaming of different pitches and lengths]
[sobbing]
[scream]
[edited sing-screaming]
[scream-singing]
[scream-eating]
[more screaming and sobbing]
[Epic Exercise dance music]
[Groans]
AW, COME ON! [Shouting]
"AW, COME ON!" [Edits video while hearing audio]
[relieved sigh] Agh...
[soft grunting] Agahhh....[Sniff]
[contented groan-humming] mmmmm......
AAARRGHH! [Scream]
*snore*
*SCREAM*
EARRAGHH! [Scream]
[quiet snore]
AURAAAGHH!
UARGHAHH!!!
How was that? That was- Was that nice?
That was good, right?
Too much screaming... just like all my videos...
Anyway, that was panic in life.
What fuck am talk about? Me no know.
Me never know.
So that's basically...an exaggeration of what
I go through in my daily life.
But I realized this morning it wasn't too terribly much of an exaggeration.
Because while I was filming that...
I got a text from someone that I was supposed to meet, 15 minutes prior to the text,
and I was horribly late, and I had to cancel on him, and
that is the entirety of my life, wrapped up in one moment.
So, I live a very sporadic life,
but that's because I have adapted to this.
And- and that's the way that I approach things.
I have so many things that I want to do
that I'm very scatterbrained.
It's not even something that's a burden on my life,
it's something that I have grown to love.
Because I love- and this is going to sound really weird
but I actually do love staying busy, and I love working,
because I love what I work on.
And I love being able to do this for my job-
and I've said this many many times before-
I'm very lucky to do this for a living.
And so, when I get an opportunity to work on something cool,
like what I do on YouTube, normally,
or when I get a chance to work on something outside of YouTube...
i-it really inspires me to keep pushing forward,
because I'd rather stay busy, and I'd rather lose sleep
right now, in the prime of my life, when I'm able to focus 100% of my effort on these things,
than do any sort of over-relaxing, or something like that.
And I'm not even saying that it's a bad thing to relax, like-
Definitely, you guys out there, take time to relax!
It's just that I... I don't want to!
I've got so much stuff to do and so little time to do it.
I've got so many projects that I want to work on right now that... I- I'm so happy.
Like I'm happy to get up early,
and I'm happy to pull an all-nighter, like...
I don't feel good doing it, but I'm happy
like, that I have the opportunity where I'm working on something that allows me to pull an all-nighter!
Like, it's a weird dissonance of like... like-
being tired and work- overworking yourself and also
enjoying what you work so much that you want to sacrifice everything for it.
And th-that's what I've always meant when I-I-I hope you guys find the thing that inspires you to that point...
You know, the thing that, like, burns inside of you in terms of motivation.
Like, this is my thing.
This is my thing that I would rather dedicate all of my time to doing than anything else,
and I love every moan-ment of it. And I hope that you guys
will eventually find your thing... that allows you to
keep pushing yourself, harder than you've ever been pushed before.
So, with that said...
I do appreciate you guys looking out for me,
sometimes I don't look out for myself.
Sometimes I'm working so hard that I forget to eat
and at various points, and then I eat way too much,
like recently, I just went to BJ's,
not sponsored by BJ's,
but they have this thing there called, 'The Pizookie',
and... Pi-zookie? Piz-ookie? Piz-o... Piz-oo-kie?
That- uh, that sounds wrong...
It's uh, it- it's a pizza-cookie...
It- it's a cookie pizza, and they put ice cream on it...
and then they drizzle it with more sugar,
and it's delicious.
And then I overeat on that, and I don't eat anything healthy...
But... it's good! I'm- n-not sponsored by it! Just... it's delicious.
90% of the things that I mention on this channel are things I'm not sponsored by,
it's just things that I actually like. So...
Take that for what you will.
I'm going to go out into the sell-out corner over here,
don't mind me.
Anyway so, uh- a-again, I'm very happy to do what I do,
and thank you guys for being with me for so long.
And thank you for putting up with the late videos...
which oddly enough, I think this video
[laughing] is going to be late by the time it gets up.
Ahhh-haaa-haaahh!
But anyway, I just- I just super enjoy what I do
and I'm happy to do it every day, so...
Thank you everybody so much for putting up with me,
and thank you for watching!
And as always,
I will see YOU in the next video.
Buh-bye!